think it's 99.999  the woman's fault if she gets pregnant  why do you think that because we are in  control of sex  we  one there's a million forms of birth  control  two you can you can  you get to pick who you sleep with yep  and three  there's condoms and four you can even  get an abortion  so i think if you get pregnant it's your  own fault so you said it's 99.9 women's  i think that men out here just shooting  up and random girls are dumb okay i  think you guys are stupid  so do you think so but but i would say  that the responsibility is mostly on the  woman rather than the guy  so i  i  don't disagree that culturally so  there is more power in the woman in  regards to getting pregnant  but